3 jours dédiés à l'optimisation de la
performance la soixantaine d'athlètes de
l'équipe police nationale a participé à
son dernier rassemblement au Centre
national de Clairefontaine un moment
privilégié à quelques mois des Jeux
Olympiques on a fait beaucoup
d'activités autour de la prépa mentale
que ce soit sur l'évaluation de la
personnalité ou sur des des points
d'ancrage pour moi c'était une
découverte déjà au niveau de de la
structure parce que c'est la première
fois que je venais ici on a pu découvrir
euh les sportifs qui ont intégré le
dispositif récemment aujourd'hui on est
65 sportifes donc c'était très
enrichissant on arrive à rencontrer des
champions médailles olympiques on se
retrouve dans à CLA fontaine dans le
centre de football enfin c'est des
opportunités que on croise pas ça tous
les jours et ben c'est ben grâce à à la
police l'objectif du séminaire le
partage d'expérience et la préparation
physique et mentale durant 3 jours les
athlètes ont pu s'essayer à différentes
activités
collectives
[Musique]
un séjour durant lequel les sportifs ont
également pu rencontrer d'anciens
médaillers également membres de la
police avec David Douillet et d'autres
sportif de niveau on est venu pour
donner nos
expériences autour des Jeux Olympiques
voilà comment aborder cette cet
événement planétaire il a du potentiel
il y a surtout un bon engouement il y a
des des jeunes qui qui sont très
ambitieux une initiative permise par la
police nationale qui soutient depuis
1982 les athlètes qui évoluent dans ces
rang on a fait un grand dîner hier soir
on a les directeurs de de la police
nationale qui sont venus à leur
rencontre et c'était important pour les
athlètes de voir à quel point en fait
l'institution
s'investit pour leur soutien et ce n'est
pas sans émotion que la commissaire a
dit au revoir à sa
promotion